there's a lot of performing characters
you know like in the performance
industry
which one out of these two do you think
houses more pedophiles
clowns
or magicians
because hear me out man those clowns
they're coming to your kids party
folding balloons and [ __ ] looking at
stuff you don't you don't know what he's
doing
but that magician
yeah
yeah and thank you for uh sorry to cut
you off man but i but i got these
buttons here and um
it's a good question and it's an age-old
question
you know it's a question you you know
you see old men talking this is
something that's been talked about for a
long time
well first of all let's look at clowns
imagine putting lipstick on your mouth
sometimes you see a man you know your
boy terry or whatever and he does a
lipstick
it's fine you know he says he was in a
fire or whatever and that's why he got
to do it everybody knows
terry never been terry never been in a
fire
you know terry sherry never been
in a fire terry [ __ ] you've never been
in a fire
so
just be if you want a woman out a little
or you want to you know
you want a small stick on them lips if
you want to do do do what you want to do
then do that
but now imagine a man
instead of just doing a lipstick he puts
a lipstick on his whole face
that's a clown
okay
that's a clown guys and that's
that's where it's alarming
you know uh
when i was young i don't know if you
could even legally be a clown when i was
young
you'd see them get pulled over all the
time they pull a dude over
we had a guy bust he was i think people
thought he just had allergies or
seasonal allergies and uh and that he
was kind of you know a
i don't want to say they used to call it
fat but he was you know kind of gristled
out you know i'm saying that uh he was
damn the lord's love seat you know what
i'm saying boy
he had a little lever on his hip you
pull on his legs it goes straight you
know what i'm saying he was that little
comfort bear
and
he uh
he was clown he was clown
and he would get pulled over and i
remember one time they pulled him over
and there was they just pulled him over
for being clown
and
the cops are trying to talk to him and
nobody you know it's still kind of vague
uh what the crime was and then he took
his own clothes off and he had his he
had more clothes painted under his
clothes
so he had
and now he's naked now it's a crime
and then
i think the one do he try to climb up a
uh invisible ladder like a mime or
whatever you know we shape [ __ ] you know
he's not shape-shifting but he's
you know wishing he was a you know
which is basically the ninja of clowns
a mime is just a damn ninja clown
that's all that is bro
a mime is just a clown that
you know that got its associates really
so he's trying to climb an invisible
ladder and the cops beat him down um
buddy what was i talking about
but i think a
clown is just somebody i think that's
afraid to ask you to touch they weiner
that's all it is i think it's somebody
that's afraid to say hey
daddy got that little spice entree you
feel me
because some clown you see the wiener
it's got paint on it that thing it's
like what's even going on here you can't
even everything's hiding so
the craziest is a female clown
when you see a female clown that's when
i
what
why what did you see
was you at a pizza party and somebody
molested you or something you know like
what
you know what i'm saying like how did
you
that's the weirdest one did somebody
like touch your titty at a comic con or
something how why are you a clown madam
why i'm not saying you can't be you can
be but
that's the one that gets me female clown
gets
me but magician magician
magician is just
magician's the one you don't you know
you don't even know you got touched by
you wake up and you shook in the head
and you shook in the crotch
and you you you know you don't you and
all you did the night before you watched
a couple card tricks and now you
molested
like it's just a lot
uh and i'm sorry i know some of this can
be triggering and maybe i shouldn't
answer this question especially on
thanksgiving
but um
and look uh a magician is really that's
the silk sheets
of satan babe because
remember silk sheets they're on you but
you can't exactly feel them
you ever get in your grandmother's bed
grandparents have silk sheets because
they freaks bro
and if they if they're not freaks
anymore they want to remember
they want that freak text tile on
you know what i'm saying they want that
spider spit all over their body they
want that silk
so you a silk sh in a silk sheet it can
be on your body and you you can
it's there but you can't fully feel it
it's like there but not there
it's just it's like ah is this keeping
me warm what is it
and then next thing you know bam
you're molested and that's a magician
it's a silk sheet of of of satan really
i feel like
so
if you had to have someone molest you
would you rather a clown or a
magician riley mal
i would say clown
oh yeah
yeah
why is that bub
i mean just look at him
yeah
i get yeah i guess you you know
you'd rather
it's a more
industrial look i think
you know it's more in it's definitely
more of like a it's more of
it feels a little more union i feel like
getting
maybe molested by a clown you know
definitely a clown huh
i don't know
yeah
yeah you second guessing or
kind of you're just not sure huh yeah
yeah
and look and look i'm sorry for even
asking you to choose man it's um
you know it's thanksgiving i don't want
you to get
you know i want you to be happy and and
joyous and free and i don't want anybody
touching you that you don't want them to
and no matter who they are or what their
occupation is
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you